foreign
was on probation for committing a cage
robbery at one Casino police say he did
it again
this time the 25 year old man is accused
of a Casino cage robbery at Resorts
World on November 10th sources tell the
8 news now investigators he arrived in a
cab went inside to commit the robbery
and left in the cap so you're on
probation for a robbery and a burglary
is a new allegation
of burglary and robbery both with use of
a deadly weapons Al jarmy was on
probation for a similar robbery at the
Venetian in 2020 and we've obtained the
evidence from the case detailing his
moves on the Las Vegas strip police say
he parks in a garage while his face is
partially covered with a scarf and
sunglasses he walks to the casino enters
goes to the cage and slips the worker a
note she hands him the money he leaves
he's seen here running his entire path
caught on cameras along with his license
plate number just a few days later he's
taken into custody in Missouri police
discovered he was in the U.S on a visa
from Jordan and they found the cash car
scarf sunglasses shoes and that note he
slipped to the worker we know where you
live don't use police alarm we are
watching you now fifteen thousand cash
police say Al jarmy told them he was
seeking asylum in the U.S he had
recently lost his job and was struggling
to make ends meet as a Lyft driver and
poker player court records show he
received a suspended three-year prison
sentence meaning he was a free man until
his arrest at a Las Vegas home this week
in court Thursday he blows a kiss to
loved ones so I won't be setting bail
you're going to be held without bail Al
jarmy's next court date is set for
November 22nd reporting in downtown Las
Vegas at the Regional Justice Center
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
the 80s now investigators requested an
interview with Al jarmy but we were told
he is unavailable at the moment